[Applause]
[Music]
into a security guard arm one
No
I was raised in Wyoming a large
commercial sheep operation we had
probably about 4,000 had a sheet that
ranged on the public lands in Wyoming
one of my jobs as a kid when I was
growing up there was they would bring
orphaned lamb Holmes me on the ranch and
I would bottle feed them this is a more
intensive operation it's more hands-on
when you do a commercial operation you
don't get to handle the Lambs like we do
here but each and every one of them we
get to handle and and work with and you
do become a little bit more attached
they have name this is wheezy there's
significant value in what we do they're
just not a product they're their lives
they're living and hate to see them hurt
if a coyote comes in and gets a lamb or
a kid goat
they're gone this Chad just let you know
they went out this morning and found
three three lambs that work I'll kill
that happened last night I know it's
just an ignoble everything here whatever
you call it but it it that's what
happens they've got the lambs up there
and the trapper will go up and get on
I don't want Kyoto dead
I just don't want coyotes killing my
animal that's as simple as it is
I didn't grow up hating coyotes I grew
up hating the fact that coyotes are
killing my sheep
I guess we we work to co-exist together
that I don't want them I don't want them
killing my sheet that has to be
understandable we talked to the hers we
compensate the herders every time they
kill a coyote we don't want them hunting
coyotes they got to be watching the
Sheep but they'll go out and if they get
a coyote they bring us a tail and and
we'll we'll compensate them the bounty
program incentivizes people to go out
and on coyote and shoot them
I've never honestly participated in the
bounty program but I think the bounty
program if it takes more coyotes then
it's helpful to me
coyote are extremely smart animals they
know when you're moving in on them they
know they consent when their existence
is being threatened you take a shot at a
coyote once and you may never get a
second shot
[Music]
they become educated very fast and so
new bounty hunters that come out
sometimes do a great job of educating
the Coyotes they don't do quite as great
a job of killing them I think a lot of
the idea is really removing coyote from
the landscape in the hopes that it will
help deer and then maybe even have side
benefits on livestock and those species
too they're all in the same range
whether or not it's helping is something
where the jury's still out if people are
thinking that we're going to remove all
coyotes from Utah lure the West that's
not going to happen the research is
really strong on this one that if you
want to reduce coyote populations you
need to remove 70% of the animals from a
given area for a few years in a row
they're incredibly reproductive they
bounce back really quickly so just sheer
numbers there's so many guys that have
to be taken to have any impact on the
population statewide it's not so much
people have moved into the Kyoto maz
we've created nice places for them to
live something with food and cover
coyotes historically were known to live
in the southwest us there's been a lot
of changes
since those times the way land use has
done things like agriculture they do
quite well in you put out that many
sheep on the landscape they'll take
advantage of that
they're very individual in the sense
that if there's a certain condition
where a Kyle could live there will be a
coyote out there they'll find a way to
live in that condition they'll adapt to
urban areas about the rural area so
because of that they've spread and
extended the range from South America up
to Alaska essentially and all the way
from the west coast to the east coast
and they show up in places like Central
Park not again in urban environments we
sort of almost encouraged coyotes to
hang with us we do landscaping we have
irrigation we have fruit trees we have
open spaces that we've preserved within
these sort of oases and it's almost and
then we when we see coyotes we tend to
either dismiss them or actually be
excited about it and take a picture with
our phone or some people actually
encourage them to come closer and so if
you think about that difference that
that urban coyote has a very different
sense of what the presence of human
beings are from a rural coyote
how you test that and research that gets
very complicated for sure
[Music]
so we're inside the predator research
facility in a lab where we're keeping
some young pups that were born in the
wild the mother of this litter was cost
deprecating on some sheep and was
legally removed from an area where
non-lethal tools had been working and
after they removed her they found again
because there's evidence that he had had
pups and was lactating and so we were
able to find the den and get these pups
and used them as part of our captive
facility now I got started in coyote
research a long time ago I did my PhD on
Kyle's I knew pretty much at a young age
as I wanted to work something with
animals and outdoors but as a child I
thought that meant you're a veterinarian
we do a lot of different things here as
a predator research facility we have
about a hundred adult coyotes in
captivity that we use to look at
different issues to reduce human
wildlife conflict and we do that through
a number of experiments both here with
captive animals and then also with wild
animals when you talk about metro areas
there's - coyote camps one camp is very
adamant they don't belong here we should
shoot them all and get rid of them and
everything will be fine
and there's another camp that's very
much we love the Coyotes we took their
habitat they were here first we need to
just live with them and by the way we
love them and and I think the biggest
challenge about what we do as
researchers and what we do as educators
is bringing those two camps together
because actually neither are very
correct
in the 90s they had a group of people
that identify themselves with members of
Animal Liberation Front that came to our
facility and tried to release coyotes
from their pens and I think they might
have used fire as a distraction while
they were releasing coyote
[Music]
it was not very successful for one ting
these coyotes are born and raised here
and so these are their territories and
so most of them didn't want to leave
their pins and they threw open they're
also very territorial animals so the
ones that did get out and get into
somebody else's territory fault the
facility had to put down a lot of
coyotes that were injured from fights
within coyotes so it ended up being
quite a bit of a tragedy for the staff
that had to work here through that time
[Music]
17 years ago I got my first horse and
started riding out here in Aurora
Colorado through riding on the trails I
met a group of people that were going to
construct a trail so I became their
first equestrian terrestrial well I've
had training and first aid and how to
communicate with the public about the
nature in Aurora including the geology
the coyotes the biology the sad things
I've seen on this trail our friend back
here I found him when he had been shot
he was dead already
but it was a fresh kill and I called the
park ranger immediately to let them know
that someone had been in the open space
with a gun which was against the law and
had killed one of our coyotes when you
just can't be shooting in guns in the
city of Denver
coyotes really do respond to hazing you
make yourself big and you yell and you
clap your hands at them you can actually
chunk rocks at them don't go after to
hit them but scare them enough and and
let them know they're not welcome in
your yard or on your street and they
usually will take off as the Coyotes
moved closer to the city and the human
population doesn't understand hazing
then the coyote start thinking of other
behaviors they start looking for cats
they start looking for dog food bowls I
hate to say this but we have a lady in
our neighborhood that actually has a
heated pet bed for a coyote to sleep in
on cold days if they will haze the
Coyotes and keep them in the urban
corridors of streams and the Coyotes
will stay down there and eat the rabbits
and the bowls and the prairie dogs like
they're supposed to and not Friskies
we do have people that don't like to
have any lethal removals going on or
legal tools being used we also have you
know some people that don't want any
normally go through venues so I figure
as long as there's people unhappy with
me on both sides of the issue that I'm
doing a pretty good job at my job
because I'm finding that balance where
we can use a majority of non-lethal
tools and only incorporate those lethal
tools when it's absolute you know final
answer
[Music]
when we send our animals out on the
mountain during the summer months
they're there on their own we stand
along with them at guard dogs they have
really helped us tremendously there they
work really well on coyote they actually
work a little more in the night time
they do in the daytime and so at night
that's when many of the predators are
most active
the other measure we like is is the
longer
the llamas of course can graze right
with them because they're they're going
to be on the same kind of a diet which
gives us a real opportunity to use those
and have them with them a hundred
percent of the time and they're there
enough of a dominant force that often
that'll just end the situation but it's
not a hundred percent by any stretch
it's no great joy for us to kill an
animal whether it's a predator
whether it's put down on one of our
sheep that's been injured or a meat goat
that's been torn up from a predator from
a coyote we find no joy in any of that
we'd be much happier if we could just go
about applying research improving our
wool quality or whatever the production
issue is we'd be much after your doing
those things and we would be controlling
predators but we have to somehow figure
out a way to survive and controlling
coyote is one of those key factors for
us this year and for the future for
urban families I totally understand rule
coyotes and that they can be a problem I
totally understand I was brought up in
the country but for urban people they
just need to learn and with them to
follow the rule that would be the only
thing that I would share and just be
mindful of our wildlife that let's
embrace them
and educate ourselves and
[Music]
here's the secret here
about wildlife management while ice
management is really a misnomer it's
about managing people and law the way
these blazing animals are easy we we
know the biology and kind of what makes
them tick we know the numbers of coyotes
that we have to remove in order to get
rid of them for instance we know that
we're not going to be able to get there
what wildlife managers have to do is
walk that tightrope between the two the
spreader paradox is this issue where we
want it all we want healthy deer
populations we want livestock to be on
her ass but we also want nature we want
you know predators on the landscape and
that's a really difficult balance to
achieve
[Music]
the fact is predators kill things for a
living that's what they do
Kyle Chilton can be devastating
especially for individuals
[Music]
the challenge is to figure out how are
we going to have all these animals but
who's going to bear the cost of it
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you